[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the
intersection of muggle and magical
taking a look at some magical aspects of
The Wizarding World that also happen to
exist in our own world from people to
magical objects join me as we unravel
the magic that has existed around us all
along mandrakes remember those
human-like roots in the Chamber of
Secrets that looked eerily like human
babies well they're real plants
mandrakes genus mandragora Come From A
genus of six species of hallucinogenic
plants in the nightshade family native
to the Mediterranean region and the
Himalayas mandrakes have a long history
and folklore and traditional medicine
with their roots used as an anesthetic
aphrodisiac and hallucinogen they aren't
deadly like their magical counterparts
but their effects can be dangerous if
misused while the Harry Potter
filmmakers took some liberties with
their physical appearance they aren't
too far off Nicola Flamel remember the
creator of the Philosopher's Stone
Nicola Flamel well he was a real person
admittedly the Harry Potter story took a
few liberties with his identity but they
weren't completely inaccurate a
real-life medieval scholar
philanthropist Alchemist scribe and
manuscript seller Flamel inhabited Paris
during the 14th century Flamel later
became known for his work in alchemy
with Legends Brewing around his supposed
discovery of the legendary Philosopher's
Stone Alchemy in Harry Potter law
Alchemy is an advanced and sort of
composite subject taught at Hogwarts
which makes this Transfiguration potions
and muggle chemistry this class teaches
students about the disciplines of an
ancient magic the study of the four
basic elements via earth water air and
how to manipulate them for the purpose
of transmuting substances
students also learn about the history of
alchemy its influence on magical
knowledge and the techniques required to
perform successful transmutations what
you may not have known however is that
Alchemy is far from being just a made-up
magical discipline in truth Alchemy was
actually the medieval Forerunner to
Modern Chemistry the practice of alchemy
dates back to Hellenistic Egypt and was
later adopted by Islamic scholars and
European philosophers even Isaac Newton
dabbled in alchemy writing extensively
on the subject bizor remember when Harry
saved Ron with a bizarre in the Half
Blood Prince well they're real Bezos are
real Stones taken from the stomachs of
goats or other animals in traditional
medicine Bezos were believed to be a
cure for poisons and illnesses
the word bizarre comes from the Persian
word padzar which means antidote while
not as universally effective as their
magical counterparts Bezos have been
used in various cultures for centuries
asphidel wormwood and wolf Spain right
near the beginning of the Philosopher's
Stone these three ingredients are
mentioned by potions Professor Severus
Snape Mr Potter our new celebrity tell
me what would I get if I added powdered
root of ass Fidel to an infusion of
wormwood you don't know well let's try
again where Mr Potter would you look if
I asked you to find me a Bazaar and what
is the difference between Monk's Hood
and Wolf Spain pity clearly Fame isn't
everything is it Mr Potter incidentally
as Fidel wormwood and wolf Spain are
actually real things asphidel is a tall
white flowering plant native to the
Mediterranean region there's a long
history in mythology and was associated
with the afterlife in ancient Greek
beliefs wormwood Artemisia absintheum is
a pleasant looking herb with a bit of
taste it is used in Liquors like
vermouth and absinthe and has been
associated with various medicinal and
magical properties throughout history
wolf Spain is a genus of Highly toxic
plants native to the Northern Hemisphere
ingesting even a small amount of
wolfsbane can be lethal and it's toxins
have been used in traditional medicines
hunting and warfare you may remember
wolfspang being used in a potion to ease
Professor lupine's werewolf symptoms in
the Prisoner of Azkaban veritaserum
veritasirum also known as truth serum
forces the Drinker to reveal their
secrets while there isn't an exact truth
serum like we see in Harry Potter there
actually are some drugs including
barbiturates that have been used as
truth serums these drugs which are
typically used for things like
anesthesia lower inhibitions and make it
harder for people to lie under their
influence the use of Truth serums has
been controversial with concerns about
their effectiveness and ethical
implications however the idea of a
potion that forces someone to tell the
truth is a long-standing concept in
fiction and mythology invisibility cloak
invisibility cloaks in the Harry Potter
Universe are magical cloaks made from
special materials that have the ability
to make the wearer invisible the most
famous of these is the Deathly Hallows
invisibility cloak which is one of the
three most powerful magical objects in
The Wizarding World it is said to make
the wearer completely invisible and is
resistant to spells and charms while we
may not have a magical cloak yet
scientists are actively working on ways
to make objects invisible using
electromagnetic waves and manipulating
light researchers have developed
materials called metamaterials that can
bend light around an object making it
appear invisible these materials are
still in the early stages of development
but they hold promise for future
applications in stealth technology and
optical devices come to think of it the
Technologies being worked on actually
more closely resembled the
disillusionment charm a spell that can
be cast on a person or an object to make
it blend into its surroundings and
become less visible the charm gives the
illusion that the person or object is
transparent or camouflaged making it
difficult to see Devil's snare you may
remember Devil's snare as one of the
obstacle articles that the trio
encountered on the way to the
Philosopher's Stone in Harry Potter
Devil's snare is a magical plant with
the ability to constrict or strangle
anything in its surrounding environment
luckily for the trio the dangerous
magical plant does have a weakness light
it's also especially sensitive to heat
as it turns out there is a real-life
version of this plant called Jimson weed
or datura stromonium it's a poisonous
Nightshade plant native to the Americas
with large trumpet-shaped flowers that
open at night just like its magical
counterparts the plant contains powerful
hallucinogenic compounds that have been
used in traditional medicine and
spiritual practices however its effects
can be dangerous and even deadly if
misused runes Hermione's study of
ancient runes at Hogwarts wasn't just
for show runes were a real type of
ancient alphabet used by the Germanic
peoples of Northern Europe and
Scandinavia the earliest runic
inscriptions date back to the 2nd
Century A.D runes were used for various
purposes including writing messages
casting spells and making predictions
today runes are popular in divination
practices and modern adaptations of
ancient Pagan religions
King's cross station and platform nine
and three quarters King's cross station
the place that witches and wizards
congregate in order to access platform
nine and three quarters is indeed a real
train station as is platform nine and
three quarters King's cross Station
built in 1852 is one of the busiest
Railway stations in the UK in the Harry
Potter series students board the
Hogwarts Express by running through a
brick wall between platforms 9 and 10.
today fans can visit a platform nine and
three quarters installation at the
station complete with a luggage cart
sticking part way into the wall the hand
of Glory in the series we come across a
hand of Glory for the first time in the
Chamber of Secrets at Balkan and Bergs a
shop that has a bit of a dodgy
reputation for selling dark Wizarding
artifacts and dealing with the
questionable witches and wizards what's
interesting about this magical item
however is that it actually exists
according to Legend a hand of Glory was
said to be able to open doors render
anyone in its path motionless or
unconscious and provide light to only
those who wield it even in total
darkness making it the perfect dark arts
object for a thief if using a hand of
Glory were the fingers provided the
light an unlit taper would also tell you
if someone in your path was awake
it's hard to put an exact date on when
the myths and legends of the hand of
Glory first appeared what we do know
however is that the term hand of Glory
derives from the French phrase
which directly translated means you
guessed it and of Glory interestingly
enough the name is said to be a
Corruption of mandragora or Mandrake as
its roots look eerily like a shriveled
hand we also know that real-life
criminals and those suspected of
Witchcraft in the 16th and 17th
centuries were accused of creating hands
of Glory to perform criminal acts and
that's it for this video can you name
other magical things from Harry Potter
that actually exist please leave a
comment down below
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live